Yeah, I'm thrilled to talk to you about, uh,
what your perspective is on what the heck we are doing wrong in places like
Kentucky. Uh, so right now you have Mitch McConnell, uh,
in some quarters, a deeply unpopular man.
Well, not just in some corners, deeply unpopular in Kentucky.
And I think that's misunderstood nationally,
but definitely deeply unpopular, not just, you know,
in big cities or in the democratic party, but in his state,
he is extremely disliked.
So let's dig into this because this isn't a very,
it's a very important misconception that a lot of people might have.
So I'm just going to speak for myself outside, looking in, uh,
Mitch McConnell seems like a very, uh,
DC oriented guy. He's been there forever. Uh, he, he,
he seems eminently unlikable. Uh,
and the impression is that somehow he has like this, uh,
mind control over the people of Kentucky where like,
everyone's like, Oh, Mitch, he's like somehow an institution.
That's what it looks like from the outside, looking in where you, you think, uh,
that like, of course I find him very unlikeable, but like you just said that,
that, um, apparently that's not unique to people outside of Kentucky.
Yeah.
One of the things I always get very frustrated about when I talk to people from
outside of Kentucky is they act like, and especially to be honest with you,
Democrats are side. They act like we're a bunch of idiots,
a bunch of dupes who don't understand how bad Mitch McConnell is. And gosh,
these stupid people in Kentucky, that's not what it is. I mean, for my book,
I went to every County in Kentucky, we have 120, which is too many,
but we have 120.
And I went to every one and finding a true Mitch McConnell
supporter is almost impossible.
Nobody likes the guy and nobody likes him for the exact reason.
You said they don't feel like he cares about Kentucky.
They feel like he's a DC person, but here's the problem.
We've never as Democrats given them.
Somebody who people believe cares more than Mitch in Kentucky.
And I think in a lot of red States,
if you have a run of the mill Republican and a run of the mill Democrat,
people are going to vote for the Republican. They just are.
So you have to do something different and you have to say,
I am different than them in a way that connects.
And the problem for the democratic party, in my opinion, in middle America,
especially is that we connect culturally,
but we don't connect economically.
And in places where the culture is not the same as a lot of the mainstream parts
of the democratic party, they just have no connection to the democratic party.
So we have stopped talking about blue collar issues, or we don't do it enough.
And that is how you use to win.
And Kentucky Democrats used to run this state forever and they talked about blue
collar. This is a working class state. This used to be a big union state.
And when does the last time you've heard a Democrat talk about unions,
don't talk about unions. They don't ever, and they,
coal mining unions were huge here. Steel unions. Like they, uh, look, you know,
this was a union place and people just don't ever bring it up. And thus,
since the culture Wars become a lot of national politics,
it hurts in places like here. And that is why Mitch McConnell,
who is deeply unliked, who workers believe doesn't care about them at all.
When it becomes a culture war battle, they end up choosing his son.
And about how Democrats have lost on the economic messaging. Uh,
and for blue collar workers, union households,
I experienced the same thing on the trail.
And one of the things that they're seeing right now between Joe and Trump is
that a lot of the union leaders are endorsing Joe and Camila because you still
have like a democratic relationship there,
but a lot of the rank and file members are voting for Trump.
And that happened at a very high level in 2016,
where the majority of these union households went to Trump,
no matter what their leaders said.
And that's going to keep happening. If we're not careful,
I think the difference, in my opinion, the reason in Michigan, Pennsylvania,
and Wisconsin Biden is doing a little better than Clinton. Is that,
that kind of rank and file union like Joe A.
Little bit better than they like Hillary.
And he talked a little bit more about this stuff, but that's where we're losing.
You know,
I speak to union groups all the time and what my message is welcome in
those, in those places.
But they don't hear Democrat politicians talking about that,
certainly on the national level. Now on the state level,
we have a democratic governor, again, Andy Beshear,
and a big part of that was because he spoke to teacher's unions. And,
and that was a big part of him getting elected.
I think we've lost that message. And, and part of the reason I really liked you,
I ended up endorsing you, which I had no intention of doing when I saw you with.
Thank you. Appreciate it. Yeah. Yeah.
And you got up and said, so you got up and told.
So I took my radio show to Iowa. It's a sports radio show,
but I wanted to do something to get different.
So I took them to the Iowa caucuses and we saw every candidate speak.
And the three guys who do the show with me, don't even care about politics.
And I was interested to see what happens at the end of this,
who will they be for? And everyone on our show was for you at the end.
And the reason was when we saw you speak,
you talked about the economic impact on small towns.
We saw you in a place called Perry, Iowa, and you got up and said, look,
no one speaks about economics in small towns and you're right, Republicans.
Don't now they'll speak about culture and social issues,
but they don't talk about the economics because it's their economic policy.
That's killing small towns and Democrats act like those places don't even exist.
And when you, you spoke about it and you're right,
America is full of small towns. And most people live in cities,
started in small towns and were just abandoned him, abandoning them and there.
And I don't know, unless we figure that out,
we're going to have a where, you know, there's going to be best swaths of land,
where people are just isolated from the economy. And, you know,
dollar general store started in Kentucky. And I wrote about this in Mitch,
please, how they go into small towns and basically ruin the communities.
They close all the local stores. They create the only place people shop.
And the next thing you know, all the money gets shipped out.
That's what I worry about across the United States.
That's a hundred percent happening right now.
And you can see dollar general and Walmart came and ran over the mom and pops.
Uh, and then now Amazon is like a spaceship. That's like sucking up,
whatever is left. Uh, and if you're in the small town,
it's not just that you're isolated.
Like when your way of life starts to degrade,
then terrible things started happening. You look around like, you know,
you have people who are still living there and as the opportunities dry up, um,
you have people drink more people, um,
and end up with the domestic violence and other problems at higher levels.
Or they never married. They, they, they never, um,
find a partner because getting married, having a child,
they're very optimistic acts like you, you, you need a degree of stability.
If you're going to get together with someone and say, Hey, let's,
let's get married, let's start a family. Let's do all this stuff. Um,
and you start kicking out the paths forward for a lot of people. Uh,
you see families deteriorate very quickly or never form,
uh I'm with you that this is the disconnect for the democratic party.
The democratic party needs to not content itself with being
the party of the urban core or of cultural
issues. Uh, I, there was a part of me, Mt. When I was running, I was like,
is there some kind of strange agenda where people prefer it?
If we talk about these cultural issues over the, the, uh,
bread and butter, the dollars and cents,
because they're just making a lot of money off us and they just want to pit us
against each other on his. And while they're laughing all the way to the bank.
I mean,
if you were to go on Fox news or MSNBC and try to argue about tax policy,
you know, I mean, who nobody's going to care, but it is what's most important.
I mean, w so I live in Kentucky. People still like Trump here.
At least a lot of people do, and I will talk to them and they'll say,
why don't you like him? And, and, and there are a million reasons,
but the thing that bothers me the most were his tax cuts.
He basically enacted Mitch McConnell's tax policy,
which has a hugely detrimental impact on the poor and the middle class.
Vis-a-vis the wealthy and people just, and it happened.
And everybody got excited because they got, you know, a check in the mail for,
for one time. And it,
it infuriates me because whatever you want to say about Trump,
and there's a lot to say when he ran. One thing he did,
I will give him credit for is he looked at these people in blue collar,
small towns, and he said, you know what? Your lives are important.
Your problems exist. And I'm going to help him. Now.
He hasn't helped him and he's full of it. And he doesn't care about him,
but at least he acknowledged them.
And we in the democratic party do not acknowledge them way too often.
I don't think it's out of maliciousness.
I just don't think there are very many Democrats who know about places like
this. I mean, there are not too many shared Browns.
There just aren't too many of those people left that are winning elections.
And so you don't hear voices like mine.
When's the last time you heard outside of James,
Carville a Southern Twain representing the democratic party.
I don't know. I mean, it just does not happen.
And I think that leads to a lot of people, you know,
Colin Powell said many years ago about African-Americans until they can see
people represented that looked like them in the Republican party,
they're not going to join it. And he was right. Well,
what's happening is in small towns.
They're not seeing people like them representing the democratic party and it's
turning them off.
And I'm living proof that if you speak to folks,
they will listen because no, one's going to mistake me for
like someone. Um, you know who, I mean, maybe they would like,
I'd appreciate you.
You come off as someone who genuinely cares. And most importantly,
you don't come off as someone who thinks they're better.
A lot of this is in places like Kentucky,
we are worried that you and the rest of the country looked down at us.
We are worried that you think we're stupid,
that you're thinking we don't know how to do anything.
And when someone talks to us like that, we turn them off. They're done.
Forget it. And I'm not going to call out the politicians that do that.
But there are a lot that do you don't do that?
I don't think Joe Biden does that.
And I actually think that's why you've seen him do better than some other
candidates is simply that notice when the democratic primaries got to the States
that are like that, Joe one in a heartbeat.
And I think you would have had success for that same reason.
You're the only two candidates in the election that I genuinely thought spoke to
people in places like this in a way.
Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation. If you did,
please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.